[Music]
i have done
two prior young jebe better health now
challenges
i decided this time around i needed an
extra push a good thing to remember is
32 pounds is the weight of my three and
a half year old son and i am
not carrying around a three and a half
year old basically
i'm a mother of four i just want to want
to see how healthy i can get so that i
can be around for a while
it's pretty amazing whenever you're
excited to get on the skills every
morning and see what the numbers are
instead of dreading it
when i went to convention last year
the day of the 5k when this lady
merle came across the finish line that
she was
visually impaired she was blind from
this day forth
i said i'm changing my lifestyle
and i'm just gonna be a whole new me i
was out of control
i really let myself go
and i thought okay who loses 12 pounds
in a week i'm like this is such a joke
but it happened and it happened again
and again and again
anybody can do this if i can do it you
can do it
leading up to today has been a whirlwind
but i feel amazing everybody makes you
feel really awesome when you come here
too so it just kind of like heightens
your excitement about everything
i feel so much better if i could help
just one person
be able to do that for their life then
it'd be worth it all
i feel amazing i can't believe how far
i've came
from last year to this year i've kept my
weight off within two to five pounds
which is a complete miracle
let's go